thank you
foreign
okay
[Music]
drop boxes are just so bad no more drop
boxes Dickinson hologic and cephe
cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney real Beauty had
to give the American people their voice
back by building something called truth
truth Central he voted against Kate's
law and he voted for Obama
amnesty as you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP Greg J.D Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy the could some of the
world's greatest cricket players from
zuchin
tendulkeron
as the great religious teacher Swami
Vive come
once said
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
the United States thank you very much he
was awarded the bronze star and the
combat infantry and badge for his
service we have to keep our country gay
people but it's not I mean for some
reason it's just not great anymore if
you care about Law and Order look Law
and Order in normal times roughly 40
percent of fresh vegetables at about 40
percent China nambia's health system is
increasingly self-sufficient this is not
about virtue cycling and signing and the
great General and President
Ulysses S Grant he's done he's really
come back a long way over the last 10
years hasn't he
appreciate it very much Tim Apple when
they gaze upon your semites your
seminites towering Sequoias they
delivered a Swift and swept in you know
that sweeping it was Swift and it was
sweeping like nobody's
ever seen anything happen units of
plasma for plasma donate plasmith into
failing New York Times by
an anonymous really an enormous gutless
coward I may ask Marilyn Lockheed
the leading
woman's business the teacher should ever
be allowed to teach transgender to our
children while out parental for yourself
no nobody has to have parental consent
and we will totally oppose the Biden
administration at this this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements on Jewish
you've heard them and you know them well
[Music]
oh
toilet showers elephants and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements and bathrooms
10 times 15 times
what on Earth is going on with Trump and
toilets
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged clogged
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation the big massive Mass
news
[Music]
God bless the United States thank you
very much elements of bathrooms mangoes
I love mangoes too
now that we are under our body's regime
my bag of mangoes now costs
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
bag of mangoes mango art mangoes like a
free boxy that's it I bought what eight
or eleven bucks
[Music]
my mango
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango material
s
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen if it's a weekend
and I'm streaming you know something big
is going on failed former president
Donald Trump expects to be arrested
Tuesday this would be the first time
ever that a former president is arrested
and indicted he will be charged with
crimes for things he allegedly did right
now and I have so much to talk to you
about right now his soviet-style uh uh
PR person is live on Newsmax let's
listen to what she's saying American
history and that's why they're doing
this it is a disgrace on our nation oh
boy absolutely triggered already huh
listen to what MSNBC had to uh say about
this had to say do we have that word
MSNBC no we don't no we we don't have it
on a certain level
look at what MSNBC is at Aaron Burnett
name is uh John Robinson Walker he gets
three million dollars from a Chinese
based company and proceeds to wire it
out to a bunch of people named Biden one
of whom is Hunter Biden another one is a
company that belongs to the president's
brother James Biden and another amount
of money to Beau Biden's uh Widow Hallie
so again from a layperson that doesn't
look good what year is that okay so that
was talking about the Biden crime family
which I think is very appropriate to
this situation because people are
panicking they don't even know what clip
it is they don't even know what year
it's from they don't even know what the
subject matter is paid the the the
president's son Hunter Biden three
million dollars we have we know other
members okay the former president is
about to be arrested and they're talking
about a laptop that a blind guy found
um we are on the precipice folks if we
are able to believe
uh what we are what we are being told
right which is and we're monitoring a
number of different things here if we
are able to believe what we're being
told
we are on the precipice of a major this
is one of the biggest stories period of
the last how many years a former
president being arrested will he be
handcuffed we don't know the answer
we'll delve into that has this ever
happened before it has not is Trump
already inciting a riot yes where do I
even start folks where do I even start
let's start I I guess I should start in
one place thanks to graveborn graveborn
just gifted 50 subscriptions the stream
just started I can't even believe what's
going on the coupon code indict is
active we all know what it means and
over on Twitch Admiral bones and your
billion as well as Thug Chuckles and
then five gifted subscriptions from Tiny
sir Jen I don't even think we can keep
up with what is going on today
where to begin
let's start with where this all started
posts from Donald Trump's uh on his
platform truth social where's my truth
sensual button truth essential Trump uh
leaking this leaking badly by the way
leaking this news hour by the way this
is in all caps so just like imagine that
it's Trump screaming our nation is now
third world and dying this is how Trump
announced 11 hours ago he's getting
arrested Tuesday our nation is now third
world and dying the American dream is
dead the radical left anarchists have
Stalin our presidential election and
with it the heart of our our country two
hours and a Stalin Stalin hour hour
American Patriots are being arrested and
held in captivity like animals like a
dog while criminals and leftist thugs
are allowed to roam the streets killing
and burning with no retribution none of
that is happening none of this is
happening millions are flooding through
our open borders like a border at a
boarding facility
b-o-a-r-d-e-r it's it's it's trash he's
posting trash uncontrollably many from
prisons and mental institutions that's
also not happening
crime and inflation are destroying our
very way of life now illegal leaks from
a corrupt and highly political Manhattan
District Attorney's office which has
allowed new records to be sent in
violent crime remember the violent crime
rate is higher in Oklahoma City than it
is in New York City this is garbage this
is Pond scum but he's building up to it
whose leader is founded by George funded
by George Source okay
indicate that with no crime being able
to be proven and based on an old and
fully debunked by numerous other
prosecutors fairy tale the Far and Away
leading Republican candidate and former
president of the United States of
America he's referring to himself will
be arrested on Tuesday of next week
protest Trump says take our nation back
and we know that when Trump says to his
followers take anything by force
you know what happens
it is going to be
I hope it doesn't happen but it is
pointing to being
an absolutely horrifying moment
not because of trump having to face
consequences that's good you do
something you should face consequences
uh but I'm horrified by the violence
that may be Unleashed Trump then posting
all sorts of other trash asking for
money
then posting some tweet who even cares
and then he's back again he says it's
time it's time for what sir
it's time for what for your protesters
to commit acts of violence and we will
ban men to ban man I don't know it's
time we are caps lock still engaged it's
time we are a nation in steep decline
being led into World War III by a
crooked politician who doesn't even know
he's alive but who is surrounded by evil
and Sinister people who based on their
actions on defunding the police the
police have not been defunded destroying
our military the military is fine open
vote borders the borders are not open no
voter ID well states have their own laws
inflation which has come down to its
lowest point since January of 2021
raising taxes has not raised them yet
has a proposal to raise taxes on rich
people and much more can only hate our
now failing USA we just can't allow this
anymore they're killing our nation as we
sit back and watch we must save America
protest protest protest
this is not looking good
this is not looking good if you're just
joining us it is believed that Trump
will be arrested on Tuesday
in New York
he says through a lawyer that he will
surrender he's not going to make them go
and get him
we don't know if he will be handcuffed
we don't know if he will be perp walked
he almost certainly will not if I mean
listen let's be honest usually they
negotiate that and then from there who
the hell knows what is going to happen
article from Yahoo from Yahoo News Daily
News it's hard to tell Trump won't
refuse to surrender if indicted lawyer
says there won't be a standoff at
Mar-A-Lago former president Trump will
not refuse to surrender if the Manhattan
district attorney criminally indicts him
his lawyer told the daily news Friday
quote this is Joe takapina the guy who
lunged for the papers last week on MSNBC
there won't be a standoff at Mar-A-Lago
with secret service and the Manhattan
DA's office
D.A Alvin Bragg is believed to be on the
cusp of nearing a charging decision in
his office's longtime investigation into
Trump and his business dealings if Trump
is charged he must surrender to New York
authorities and appear in court to enter
a plea a judge could theoretically
conduct the hearing remotely but no
criminal defendants are being arranged
virtually at present according to Lucian
chalfin from the office of Court
Administration
D.A staffers met with members of nypd's
intelligence Bureau on Thursday for a
preliminary meeting to address security
concerns ahead of the possible
indictment yeah the other security
concerns are maggots running wild on the
streets of New York that's another
security concern which I hope is being
taken very seriously
the NYPD did not immediately respond to
a request seeking information about
preparations
grand jury proceedings are confidential
it is not known whether the group and
paneled will vote to indict Trump on and
on and on
what are the charges for sources
connected to the investigation say Bragg
is considering charging Trump with
crimes related to how he and his
business classified reimbursement checks
to his former fixer Michael Coleman A
friend of the David packman show by the
way Michael Cohen for the hush money
payment to Daniels and concealed the
payment to hide a second crime on
Wednesday Cohen testified before a grand
jury hearing evidence in the probe he
said every one of the engaged jurors
asked him a question and added he was
certain he provided the most
comprehensive account of the hush money
with stormy for which he served federal
prison time
wow this is going to be a Bonkers day
let's read about what or let's listen to
what's happening with security
preparations for the Trump arrest
scheduled for Tuesday as far as we know
ladies and gentlemen Donald Trump here
to the Manhattan District Attorney's
office to answer to these charges which
would include a full booking process
from the fingerprinting the mug shot and
then of course Raymond as well because
of the publicity it certainly would be
expected that this would happen away
from the crowds away from the cameras
but it is all yet to be seen Paula would
steal a lot of uncertainty about the
where but one thing is for sure law
enforcement here in New York they
certainly want to be prepared for
whatever comes their way yep Polo
Sandoval thank you and we have heard
that at least some members of the former
president's legal team are encouraging
him to at least ask for a remote hearing
but joining me now to talk about all of
the aspects of this Renato Mariotti is a
former let's listen a few minutes and
then I've got more stuff it's
complicated podcast I'm so glad you're
here first off let let's just talk about
this case a lot of the facts are are
public what do you make of the case
itself how strong is this
I think it's pretty weak Paula you know
certainly of the potential cases that
former president Trump is facing it
certainly appears to be the weakest I
agree obviously we don't know everything
about the case but I have a lot of
questions about it you know they have to
prove for example the intent to fraud
it's not uh clear with the evidence of
that is uh this is a fairly novel legal
Theory so definitely some questions
um and you know I think the former
president team is likely to fight this
one pretty aggressively
agreed now we've asked a bunch of people
on this show already about the time and
that seems to be one of the big
questions
this is conduct that occurred
approximately seven years ago this
investigation has been going on for four
or five years is there anything based on
your experience that could help to
explain why we're suddenly seeing this
heating up in recent weeks
this is the weirdest thing this is
seltzer I don't even have Seltzer at
home it's very strange another related
question is why is the Manhattan ta
bringing charges based on this fact
pattern when he actually previously
um had declined to bring charges in a
case that I think appeared to be
stronger the case that ultimately was
picked up and brought it is a civil
lawsuit by these okay generals so let's
discuss where do we want to go first do
we want to go to the things that right
Wingers will be saying to defend Trump
if he gets arrested on Tuesday I can go
there first or I can do a brief
nutritional interlude with some weird
stuff that I got in response to a video
people let me know what you want to go
to first I do want to say thank you to
James for gifting five YouTube
subscriptions putting us at 63. I also
want to say thanks to S Prez for gifting
25.
um twitch subscriptions putting us at 88
also a big thank you to Pete pizza man
as well as lokiara for putting us at 90
and then the first person today using
today's coupon code indict is Desiree
Delong our longtime supporter Desiree
Delong great to see you and a big thank
you also to Jason sickmeyer who just
gifted a subscription if you want a free
membership just go to davidpackman.com
free membership it's a really easy URL
free membership at davidpackman.com
membership okay let's do the responses
first and then we'll do the weird
nutritional interlude okay so here's the
deal here are the five big defenses we
are going to hear if Trump is arrested
on Tuesday and we will deal with each of
them one by one
first one you are going to hear I
already saw it on uh on Newsmax let's
see if they're actually doing it now
um
no they're not talking about that right
now okay I saw it on Newsmax before
this is evidence of a two-tier justice
system
one tier for republicans and another
tier for Democrats it's bogus now it is
a absolutely true statement that there
is a two-tier justice system it is for
the wealthy and the elites who can
afford the best lawyers and negotiate
every aspect of the charges coming at
them and everybody else we have a
two-tier justice system it is not one
for republicans and one for Democrats
that's the first thing you're going to
see this is evidence of a two-tier
justice system politically motivated
secondly I already saw this uh put out
there by some right Wingers
the charges are coming right now because
Trump is just crushing everybody in 2024
polls and Democrats are desperate well
that's an interesting one that we can
fact check and unfortunately for those
perpetuating that narrative
Trump is actually doing worse than
DeSantis against Joe Biden if you look
at the polling so the argument that they
needed to do this because Trump is
soaring in the polls if we look at an
Emerson College poll
um completed three days ago and released
this is an A minus rated pollster
Biden versus DeSantis DeSantis is
winning by three Biden versus Trump it's
a statistical tie Biden plus one so
claim Trump is surging in 24 polling so
Democrats need to hurt him
legitimate polling says DeSantis is
doing better not the only example uh
this is a Rasmussen poll of just Arizona
Let's ignore that for the time being
next a rated poll a minus Quinnipiac
University Biden DeSantis Biden plus one
Biden Trump Biden plus four
multiple a minus rated pollsters say
Trump does worse against Biden than
DeSantis so that's the second claim that
they're making Democrats need this
because of the timing because of what's
happening in the polls it is not
backed up substantiated by the facts
third claim that the prosecutors I'm
sorry that the investigators looking at
this in Manhattan resigned because there
was no reason to charge Trump that's a
blatant lie we covered the story when it
was going on the truth of what happened
in Manhattan is that investigators
resigned because they found we have so
much evidence against Trump but it's
clear the D.A isn't willing to indict
their claim is the resignations were
because there was no evidence the
reality is the resignations were because
there was evidence and the investigators
felt that their work was a waste of time
because there was no actual interest in
indicting it appears as though the
investigators were wrong if indeed Trump
will be arrested so third claim was
we already heard from the investigators
there was no evidence no we heard from
the investigators there was evidence
they didn't think an indictment was
coming that was a waste of time uh 4
claim that this is uh yeah the fourth
claim it's sort of a general one this is
just merely politically motivated it's
just political motivation oh let's see
what let's see what Pence is saying
about this events of Americans and
particularly happening in what appears
to be a politically charged environment
in New York where the attorney general
and other elected officials literally
campaigned
on a pledge to prosecute
but the person now in charge of this
indictment is not one of those people so
that that's a very cowardly statement to
make okay the fourth claim is that it's
just like generally political that it's
just a political basically what Pence is
saying these are partisan actors and
that's what's going on
I can't read my I can't see what the
fifth one is hold on a second
resigning investigators polling two-tier
justice system political damn it I had a
fifth one and I can't even read my own
handwriting it looks like I wrote vodka
but I know that that's not what it can't
possibly be vodka what's the fifth claim
that they're making does anybody know
damn
vodka that no Vicodin what does that say
I genuinely can't tell
anyway there was some fifth claim that
we were hearing
uh uh some people are saying deep State
yeah I mean they might say deep State
that's that's true some of them might
say deep State okay so anyway did I
write it in Spanish no I don't think so
um there was some fifth thing if it
comes to me I will uh I will certainly
let you know welcome if you're just
joining us
descent no it wasn't that damn it I
really wish I could remember what this
fifth one was
[Music]
but damn it I just can't what is that
looks like the VN followed by the number
two I I don't know Vladimir
I just can't tell what it is
Ivanka no
Hillary no all right listen let's move
on I just can't tell I can't tell what I
wrote it's just it's crazy
I wrote it I wrote it 15 minutes ago and
I forgot and I also can't read it I mean
it's just this this is an embarrassing
stream I'm sorry it was put together
very very quickly all right thank you to
Napa skip dog and liquid ice for the
twitch Prime subscriptions putting us at
94. I also want to say a huge thank you
to Christopher B Christopher B just
signed up on my website joinpakman.com
with the coupon code indite
I think we all understand the code
and also thanks to William stadden who
is new member number 96. all right
really brief
uh oh Super Chat Mark says hey David
from the UK If Trump has real inside
info he'll be arrested Tuesday would it
benefit him to hand himself
involuntarily at this point his lawyer
says he will his lawyer says he's not
going to resist so that's already the
plan
um Haley from Maryland says Trump comes
to the judge tears in his eyes and says
sir sir I did not have sexual relations
with that woman yeah I don't know if
that's going to be a functional defense
to be perfectly Frank uh
Haley but he may who knows what he will
try he could try anything all right let
me do a very very brief interlude
um this was just kind of a weird thing
so the other day we did this segment
Trump Republican having to flush her
toilet multiple times this is Tudor
Dixon who is a failed Republican
candidate she was endorsed by Trump and
she went on TV and she did the flushing
toilets thing and she said you know I
can't even I need multiple flushes
essentially and what I said was that's
more of a dietary problem she probably
needs more fiber not really like a Joe
Biden problem Joe Biden didn't do
anything to her toilet and the this only
went live a few hours ago and I got four
emails this is the weirdest thing in the
last few hours I got four emails from
people saying basically some version of
listen David
the segment is funny and it's funny
she's talking about flushing toilets and
all of that stuff but to be perfectly
honest I I don't know how to get fiber
in my diet is this a thing like is this
act I this is not a topic we normally
delve into on the show but hearing
people four people in just two hours
taking time to email me and saying all
joking aside like it's not you I don't
know how to get fiber in my diet is this
actually a thing
people are saying it is that's
interesting the American diet has a
serious lack of fiber
do a fiber channel fiber is not in the
American diet
wow
this is this seems to be a thing mangoes
are too expensive
that is super interesting
yeah I mean listen this isn't really A
nutrition show but it this you this
doesn't have to like
this doesn't have to this isn't the most
complicated thing if you I don't know
what the fiber requirement suggestion is
I imagine that it's like 30 grams a day
imagine you would eat three meals and
like I ate three meals and two snacks
I'm like a five meal a day sort of guy
um you you basically need like six to
eight grams per meal this stuff isn't it
this really isn't complicated no I don't
have any sponsor I don't have any fiber
sponsor
no listen folks
breakfast okay imagine you're like an
eggs and toast person for breakfast okay
the egg has no fiber but beautiful
protein absolutely beautiful protein if
you're having toast
make it whole wheat okay three grams
boom right there slice a whole wheat
toast you got three grams of fiber
um slice up half an avocado I love this
with my egg and toast half an avocado
beautiful five grams of fiber you've
already got eight grams of fiber and
what I love with breakfast is uh fruit
okay I I know people joke about the
mango I cut up a little mango
um blueberries raspberries raspberries
are shockingly high in fiber okay you
get yourself alongside your eggs and
toast with avocado you get yourself a
little bowl of berries and uh and
blueberries
that's probably another three or four
grams you're already a third of the way
there like this this really I I'm it no
you don't need a bag of my of mangoes
you don't need anything okay you go to
lunch what do people have for lunch
these These Days soup and sandwich is
that what people have or sandwich and
salad
right
if you're having a sandwich for lunch
you do the whole wheat bread it's two
slices that's six grams or like I like
to have salad alongside whatever if I've
got leftover lasagna
or a sandwich you get a salad literally
okay
a little handful of chickpeas on your
salad boom another six grams of fiber
you're already close to 20. 22 20 I mean
this folks this really doesn't have to
be difficult
um
yeah I'm completely guessing at these
numbers but I think it's more or less if
you have a snack at some point in the
day okay you have a snack you make
yourself trail mix you get some almonds
and some walnuts a few raisins put in a
few chocolate chips there's nothing
wrong with some dark chocolate chips
those also have fiber folks you're done
this is like this really doesn't have to
be complicated so I apologize the the
real topic today is actually Trump
getting uh getting getting arrested very
very soon but the number of emails I got
after the flushing toilet thing from
people saying I don't know I don't know
I'm struggling with this fiber thing it
really doesn't have to be uh really
doesn't have to be difficult all right
let's continue because we've lost three
quarters of the audience during the
fiber round I want to say thank you to
Adam Garber who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code indict
folks this is the day for that coupon
code other super chats coming in sir
there's been apprehension about
arresting a former president will this
open the door for for more indictments
this is exactly what I wanted to get to
next
I do believe oh by the way I see people
asking about psyllium husk and chia
seeds yeah this is like you keep it in
your back pocket right if you're if
everything I'm doing with the avocados
and all the stuff that I'm suggesting if
it doesn't work
quite literally if you have yogurt you
just sprinkle psyllium husk powder or
add some chia seeds and then okay so
there's no excuses seriously folks on
the fiber thing there really is isn't
okay
I agree
that these charges that are expected
against Trump
are
um the weakest
I think that the stuff out of Georgia is
potentially much stronger I think that
the stuff out of DC is potentially much
stronger but my hope is the reason I
welcome these charges is exactly what AJ
is saying right here
okay that these charges may make it so
that the other prosecutors realize I
don't have to be first anymore they've
already indicted them let's now move
because I've said that there is this
hesitation to be the first ever to
charge a former president people in the
chat saying the Georgia case is the
strongest I tend to agree so the hope
would be
that these initial charges will open the
floodgates for lack of a better term and
uh we'll find out the the expectation
now is that Trump will be arrested on
Tuesday let's listen to Sebastian Gorka
and what he's saying conservatives have
why because we believe in the individual
we don't act like a collective of you
know a zombie Hive the left is a
collectivist entity that is the this
kind of ideology they all of a sudden
they're philosophers when their guy is
accused of crimes and is about to get
arrested all of a sudden it's the
philosophy of collectivism
dude there's evidence to charge them
that's what's going on it's a Russian
asset he's a traitor he's a misogynist
he's a white supremacist he's a Neo-Nazi
that's what they've been telling us who
said that who said Trump is a Neo-Nazi
that one I didn't hear down because he's
a threat to democracy not those who
actually support no cash bail for the
likes of antifa for BLM those who it's
antifa sir violence like remember we had
members of Congress like Waters say if
you see a member of the Trump cabinet if
you see them filling up their car with
gas surround them harass them we have
the former attorney and Marjorie Taylor
green said the same thing about people
that disagree with her you kick them
when they're down you had Chuck Schumer
outside the Supreme Court say Gorsuch
Kavanaugh you will reap the Whirlwind
this is the collective now if there's
somebody who's financing it we know who
it is you've mentioned it you look at
the races for these offices for the DA's
positions George Soros there it is
George Soros individual but when it
comes to who's behind it it's though
it's the Borg it's a it's a hive mindset
there you go very compelling stuff
George Soros responsible for the uh
apparently forthcoming arrest of failed
former president Donald Trump megwine
says via Super Chat super chat's coming
in almost faster than I can address them
David Sir with tears in my eyes I love
your strong opinions about food thank
you
um hey David I have an aunt who worked
in the DA's office in New York when I
asked her about Tuesday she says she's
afraid it'll only boost his supporters I
still can't wait to see it oh yeah it's
not at all obvious to me that getting
arrested will hurt Trump
uh I I completely am on board there
Larry Ty says let's hope there's no
violence but do you think they'll
somehow find a way to blame it on antifa
even if some were to wear Camp Auschwitz
hoodies yes if there is any violence on
Tuesday it will be blamed on the left
without a doubt without a doubt is it is
I mean of course of course
um let's see what else we have here
uh Sebastian Gorka sounds like he could
be a dark Overlord in a fictional video
game he really does yeah he absolutely
does big thank you to Pilot dog who just
signed up via twitch Prime also want to
say thank you to
uh no one thank you to no one okay let's
continue let's look at a couple of uh
recent elements that were posted to
Twitter Let me refresh this we've got a
lot of very very interesting stuff here
[Music]
um
okay so this is the interview with Pence
let's look at this Donald Trump is
saying that he's going to be indicted on
Tuesday he's calling for people to
protest now we we don't know that's true
um that Matt and D.A has not said
anything about it uh but he's calling
for people to protest uh is that
irresponsible well first let me say I'm
taken aback at the idea of
indicting a former president of the
United States
at a time when there's a crime wave in
New York City uh what a loser what about
the crime wave in Oklahoma City with a
higher violent crime rate than New York
City why do they do this question do you
think Mike Pence really doesn't know
that the crime rate is higher in
Oklahoma City than in New York City or
do you think he knows but he knows that
this is the thing he's supposed to say
is he an idiot or is he a bad person or
is it both
the fact that the Manhattan D.A thinks
that indicting President Trump is his
top
priority I think is just tells you
everything you need to know about the
radical left in this country it's a the
last five years Democrats have been
dismantling
tough criminal justice in the city of
New York families are paying the price
and yet this is what we get it just
feels like a politically charged
prosecution here uh and I for my part of
how would Pence know that he doesn't
even know what evidence there is he
doesn't even know what the charges are
just feel like it's just
not what the American people want to see
but he's calling on people to protest to
come out and protest take our nation
back we know what happened the last time
he said that
well John the American people yeah you
almost died Pence the last time Trump
had people protest institutional right
but to have a former president Khan
people to protest a a a a a all right so
I think we get it Pence is an absolute
complete and total coward like complete
and total coward in every way and he's
uh extraordinarily pathetic and I don't
expect anything uh in his political
future I want to say thank you to Jackie
lay who just re-upped the twitch Prime
subscription and also bully Bay bull Bay
who just gifted four subscript five
subscriptions via twitch let's go for
200 my friends over via super chats
David Roberts says hindsight being 20 20
would it have been better if kovit got
Trump like if covet killed Trump I would
never
I would never ever ever uh delve into
that uh that I would never wish death
upon anyone in that way
but it's it's quite a question uh okay
that one we dealt with
brand of ham says am I the only one that
still feels doubts about Trump's arrest
and if he was arrested then would he
actually be in prison if so then how
long folks I have been saying this for
years
Trump might be indicted but Trump is not
going to see a day of prison Trump is
not going to see a day of prison I stand
by it if people want to bet memberships
on that I'm glad to do it Trump is not
going to prison
these charges are just a holding charge
while New York builds the largest case
for the tax fraud that Leticia James is
working on in Civil Court that's uh
David Greenberg's idea possible
David sir don't forget the what about us
some excuses oh
Hunter that's what I had that was the
fifth thing this is the fifth thing I
had written down
what this should really be focused we
should really be focused on Hunter
Biden's laptop that is exactly the fifth
item I couldn't read it wasn't vodka it
was Hunter
um yes exactly right Dana that is
exactly right
um okay is the fifth defense of trump
possibly to offer the judge vodka just
spitballing no no no no
um uh Dana got it Dana got it right all
right let's continue seeing some of the
recent uh elements that have been
mentioned here regarding the forthcoming
Trump arrest
uh let's see what we have here
um
here's a comment from Fox News let's see
what this is about ends up coming to
fruition or not it sticks but what this
is also going to do it's going to fire
up the mega crowd maybe those people
that were possibly leaning more towards
Iran DeSantis now they go here we go
again another Witch Hunt against our guy
I'm standing firm with Donald Trump and
I also think that this is a motivation
of the left I think that they would
rather have Trump supporters Galvanize
behind Trump because I think that they
know that Trump is easier to beat than
Ronda Santos well now I actually am with
this uh woman in the sense of in the
sense of
I do think that Trump supporters will be
galvanized by Trump getting arrested I
do think that part is true
I do think that part is true that being
said elections and crimes are two
totally different things and being
interested in one versus the I mean it's
a little weird it's all a little a
little bit strange
um okay let's see what else we have
related to this forthcoming alleged
arrest
um
oh I guess Tulsi sets up do we want to
take a brief tool see interlude because
I guess Tulsi said something crazy let's
just see
celebrate
I couldn't believe it when I saw in this
last state of the union speech how many
members of Congress are walking around
with a big abortion pin on their suit
jacket
not just advocating for but celebrating
abortion on depend on demand without
exception
all the way up until birth or even after
birth normalizing infanticide we've seen
this in places like New York and yeah
that's absolutely not happening and
Tulsi is disgusting and pathetic and I
never want to hear from her again quite
frankly okay a super chat from Bobby
Polo hello I am what you consider a
hardcore trumpy there are much more
meaningful topics that can be spoken
about currently are you open for debate
so a couple different things this
particular stream is about Trump
apparently being about to get arrested
being very close to getting arrested so
that you can always say there are other
things to talk about like when I talk
about Healthcare it's like why am I not
talking about climate change or when I
talk about DeSantis why am I not talking
about Tim Scott or whatever
this stream is about the forthcoming
allegedly forthcoming arrest of trump
first of all am I open for debate sure
call in absolutely anytime
and
um
you can ask me anything you want all
right thank you if he's indicted that
does that mean he can no longer be in
the race okay this is a really good
question from micro Kimmy
it is not clear to me that he would be
forced to drop out because he is
indicted remember an indictment is just
an allegation
um it is not a conviction and uh even if
convicted I don't know that he could be
forced to drop out so no he won't have
to the question is if he's indicted
multiple places is it just going to be
practically speaking impossible to keep
things going
uh and that remains to be seen Isha Oak
Xavier just grabbed a twitch Prime
subscription and his number 105 today
um okay let's look at a few more things
here that are happening here is Marjorie
Taylor green calling for Hillary Clinton
to be locked up despite no charges we
need to put Hillary Clinton in jail
for what
[Music]
yeah lock her up that's right
we are not going to have people hacking
and breaking in and spying on the
president of the United States I don't
care what political party they are well
investigate her find evidence bring
charges arrester indictor try her and
then lock her up if she's found guilty I
mean go but you know go ahead go ahead I
don't care who
if there's evidence follow the evidence
that's all I ask oh Hillary lock up
Hillary give me a break
um here is Vivek ramaswamy running
against Trump I guess he's not big on
this forthcoming arrest
[Applause]
ing what
is or should be an elephant in the room
which is that
I want to be crystal clear that we
should not want to live in a country
where the party in power is able to use
police force
to arrest its political opposition and I
do not want to I don't want to live in a
country we're just because you are or
were the president you can't be held
accountable for wrongdoing or you can't
be investigated I don't want to live in
a country like that vivec okay see that
day come to pass in this country notice
that there's no discussion here of is
there evidence
is it reasonable to think Trump
committed it doesn't matter he's like I
just don't want
political people arrested but it is not
the subject of my speech here today but
it's too important thank goodness
because he's making no sense I have a
topic not to mention I'll be outside
this room talking to anybody afterwards
who wants to be talking about it because
I think we need more people yeah he's at
the point in the campaign right now
where he will quite literally speak to
anyone uh which is which is interesting
I think we lost our CNN feed here let me
see if I can get it back
we may have lost the CNN feed
interesting uh meanwhile over on Fox
News uh uh there's commercials I guess
and Newsmax also commercials very a lot
of commercials happening right now
that's for sure
kind of it's all kind of strange all
right thanks to grant for the twitch
Prime subscription your 100 number 106
today as we are here on this Saturday
evening I do want to say thank you to
Victoria schwimly who just signed up on
my website with the coupon code indite I
will say this once and only once today
folks we do primarily depend on people
who sign up on my website to support
everything we do the daily podcast the
Spanish Channel dubbing all these
different things if you have cable four
bucks a month goes to Fox News you you
don't have any say over it unless you
get rid of cable altogether okay what
I'm saying to you is if you use the
coupon code indict on my website for two
bucks a month you support just this show
all but 2.9 percent comes to us and you
get the daily bonus show you get invited
to the commercial to the members only
Town Halls you get a a sound board we
now have for members a soundboard
[Applause]
with the clips I play it's accessible to
our members and honestly this is really
the best way to fund what we do because
no one can then have me over a barrel
imagine that as many people say we were
funded by George Soros that's a claim
that's made it's a lie it's a lie but
it's a claim that's made
if you're funded by one rich guy
that one rich guy can end you
when we distribute our funding just over
everyday folks like you the good thing
is no one person can control what I do
the bad thing is if you tell me I'd
better change my tune on X or you'll
unsubscribe I'm also going to ignore you
I'll just be completely upfront about
that okay but you can sign up at
joinpakman.com your name will come up on
I have a monitor reserved just for
people who do this and I will thank
every single one of you okay
um Charisse Campbell from tenopa Arizona
says your work is so important in this
strange and scary political atmosphere
thank you for your educated and logical
Insight a refreshing voice in the
political realm I really appreciate that
Charisse and Charisse has been um a
supporter for a while as far as I can
remember anyway okay let's get back to
some of these other uh things that are
that are now coming out
um based on the the belief forthcoming
Trump indictment
we're not going to hear from Beau Bear
right now let's see what else we have
Nikki I don't really want to hear from
Nikki Haley at this particular point in
time
but I will at some point I'm sure there
was apparently some kind of right-wing
event that there's a lot of Clips
floating around from I did I was not
aware of that uh let's see what Hannity
has to say why do we show you Joe Biden
on tape laughing about fentanyl deaths
we'll show you that next
WoW an absolutely riveted and extremely
diverse crowd you've got you know white
guys wearing ties and white guys wearing
sweaters and white guys wearing shirts
but an open jacket and you've okay all
right anyway let's let's keep going with
us
um
what else do we have Tim Scott spoke at
this event maybe there isn't that much
else that has been floated so far
Mike Pence's fundraising off of Trump's
potential indictment what
then Ernie gave
us rebuke of the former president
talking about his actions on January 6.
clearly trying to distance himself from
Trump that's clearly not the case today
and if you have any indication of where
he or his allies believe and that's
Trump this stands politically he said he
sent a fundraising email about 10
minutes ago fundraising off of this
potential indictment Paula it's one week
ago what
well I would like to see that email
uh would have liked to have seen it
presented there
um okay
let's see what else we have here that we
may really not have much else to look at
as far as uh
new video from Trump let's say patriotic
Americans are being prosecuted for
peacefully protesting a stolen election
oh this is from the Republican
accountability project okay we would
let's let's move over that Kevin
McCarthy is trying to interfere with
Trump's indictment as I would expect him
to do
um
okay so there may not be too many other
public statements yet it may it may just
all be very early
Kurt Cameron Dear God
Blackburn not not a big uh not a big
Blackburn fan I have to say
um okay
so let's
um
oh they're still going let's see what
gork is up to now on this puts the dog
what this is It's a demonstration of
absolute corruption and you're right
when I traveled across the country and
crowds came out for us and we didn't
even have President Trump with us we
just had his photo on the side of a boss
mind you women for Trump
they were doing events with Trump's
picture we couldn't get the real Trump
but we did have a picture and people
loved it impression that nobody has ever
seen before you don't have to protest in
assembly you can protest with prayer you
can protest by getting people out there
registered to vote I think she's worried
that the protesters if Trump is arrested
are going to be very violent so she's
like you know protesting by staying at
home and praying is just as valid you
can do that too what they're doing
because now he is the
quarantine what a victim not Trump he
lost businesses lost family members and
now we are seeing our country being
invaded so thank you Dr Gorka absolutely
you're gonna see the I come back and by
the way Dr Jill Biden no she's not a
medical doctor no
Dr Gorka not a medical doctor Orca keep
it right here everybody we got a lot
more coverage right here on Newsmax
[Music]
all right so they're you know a very
strange reactions on that channel I have
to say big thank you to Tony Davis Tony
just signed up on my website using the
coupon code indict which is a very
strong coupon code at this point in time
Austin says via Super Chat David sir we
love you and baby and girlfriend hashtag
Ultra Pack it's like Ultra Maga but less
dangerous I think is the way I would I
would say it and welcome back to office
drummer office drummer I don't know how
many of you follow office drummer on
Twitch or on tick tocks but office
drummer creating some Quality quality
content and uh great to see you back
here I don't really know office drummers
uh real name
is it like Chris or something I'm not
sure
uh Phil no I doubt it's Phil I would bet
against Phil
Solomon now I very much doubt that it's
all Richard oh Richard welcome all right
very good
um
office drummer anxiously awaiting
Trump's indictment very strongly all
right and thanks to Julianne Bartos for
signing up on my website as well new
member number 110.
um mega nut jobs think they're going to
New York City armed NYPD has a 10
billion dollar budget they will
accommodate Mega nut jobs with a comfy
stay at hotel Rikers yeah I am
interested to see
weather so you know it's sort of like
well where would they Riot on Tuesday if
Trump is arrested the natural
expectation would be if Trump's arrested
in New York they would riot in New York
a lot of them don't live in New York so
they would have to go to New York and
then like do they bring their guns or do
they not and then it it really could get
very very ugly very very quickly I would
be more you know maybe they'll just like
be like I don't know I'm in Ohio we'll
protest in Ohio somewhere I'm not sure
um maybe they'll go to DC
yeah maybe they'll just show up outside
Trump's Mar-A-Lago and protest there
yeah listen guys
Anything could happen anything could
happen look at this pillow commercial I
know
wow it's so soft and smooth it's cool to
the touch how did you do that well we
took my pillows patented bill look at
this new technology that we didn't have
back then when I invented my pillow to
bring you the best pillow in history my
pillow 2.0
just like all of you this is
unbelievable what could get any better
that's why I haven't changed it in
nearly 20 years then I heard about a
revolutionary new technology and I knew
I had to bring it to y'all my pillow 2.0
is truly the next generation of my
pillow it's filled with Bibles oh it's
cooler and softer than the last my
pillow it is so comfortable to sleep on
at night I look forward to going to bed
and I wake up well rested in the morning
sleep is all about temperature and
height my pillow height height what does
that even mean it's going to give you
the exact individual support you need
from your head to your bed and now
here's where it gets even better we've
all experienced those temperature
related sleep interruptions where you
get too hot you toss and turn you flip
your pillow over to the cool side well
all that's gone with my brand new
MyPillow 2.0 cooling fabric that's made
with remember that it seemed last week
like pillow was actually going broke but
then after that report came out he's
like no we're fine a new MyPillow 2.0
call or go to mypillow.com now use your
promo code and for a limited time when
you buy one you'll get a second one
absolutely free you're sleeping even
better and cooler too and you're looking
good feeling good is pillow in the
mirror with a what a weird commercial
huh
okay so anyway pillow's still
advertising welcome to Twitchy twitcher
10 the third with a twitch Prime
subscription putting us at 111. Super
chats keep dumping in Haley says my
pillow equals bag of mangoes uh all
right here is the latest from Newsmax
besides its consideration makes clear no
one is above the law not even a former
president of the United States the
former president's announcement this
morning is reckless doing so to keep
himself on the news and to foment unrest
among his supporters joining us now is
pretty good statement from Pelosi I must
say Newsmax has a completely unhinged
panel they've just welcomed Rudy let's
see if Rudy's hair melts and let's see
what he has to say
outside of trading
woman became committing a crime for you
and me
that she has blocked being applied to
Congress for 20 years is Rudy okay a
husband could crookedly become
millionaires by trading on inside
information she's the queen of its diet
information and she's a direct result of
Baltimore Democratic politics should
know that but in any event
the real damage here is to the United
States of America no this this is uh it
would be damaging if presidents were
Above the Law the worst in the Saturday
night Massacre because uh only in a
fascist government would you have a
political prosecution
and you have to be uh
either so partisan or really dumb not to
realize this is a purely political
prosecution he has no evidence to back
that up just to be clear principal
prosecutors off
he's actually
from her
is that background noise from whatever
room Rudy is in do you guys hear that
strange background noise
which was an actual felony perjury
this is a made-up misdemeanor
this guy took 52 percent of the felonies
in New York and made them misdemeanors
as a result of that people were thrown
on subways beaten up and are leaving the
city and drove the man is a disaster of
a district attorney he's a disgrace and
a disaster and he wasn't paid for by Joy
I like the anchor nodding as if she has
any idea fascist country
you can't do political prosecutions and
what we know as America
so any Democrat like uh Queen the queen
of insider trading who doesn't condemn
this is basically endorsing wow these
people are coping hard right now
there are 50 Soros DA's all around the
country getting people killed
disproportionately young black people
Mr marify May first things first uh I
want to salute you here
um on Newsmax because you are the
opposite you are the antithesis when you
were a prosecutor you were the opposite
of Leticia James of Alvin Bragg so God
bless you for what you did even before
you became mayor but you mentioned
George Soros a man who gave more than a
million dollars to Alvin Bragg's
campaign how do we stop that how do we
stop a nearly 100 year old man from
controlling literally everything and
everyone have you thought of any way to
insulate us from this in the future
right I mean there would have to be
limits on campaign contributions and
then you'd have first amendment I mean
it has it has to be the electorate there
have been a couple of Elections where
his candidates were decisively defeated
because the people didn't want him
coming in and dictating the D.A now he's
got about 50 he got he's got about 50 of
them it isn't like uh these are the
people by the way Lydia who who dropped
the cases against the uh against the
rioters in 2020. all right so Rudy not
making a ton of sense big thanks to
Jones and the Ki weasel for signing up
via twitch Prime I really appreciate
that it's a very special night we have
the coupon code indict going big thank
you to Angela Freeman Joe Rader and
Richie Cooper zand for signing up and or
gifting subscriptions at joinpakman.com
folks I have free subscriptions
available if you cannot afford a
membership for yourself go to
davidpackman.com free membership to
request a free one do not email me every
time when I say this someone emails me
and goes David how do I get the free
subscription I hit the delete button it
goes right in the trash guys I'm being
really clear
davidpackman.com free membership that's
the only way to request one Larry says
fun fact I joined truth Central the
other night when I was a little drunk my
username is and we will ban men and my
profile is just one relevant Costanza
quote I see things as they are and I say
no well congratulations Larry I hope
that your experience on truth is a
is a is a good one let's get back to
Rudy here for a bit who is coping very
very hard quitted uh I also have faith
that unfortunately in a certain way
or maybe fortunately uh he's gonna be
elected president if they go through
with this the American people I mean
look you guys hear a kid yelling several
of them have been on television today
this is an outrage these are Democrats
who hate Trump
but they realize Weissman for example I
think I just heard someone say papa
image
that this is doing
to our system of justice we can't even
say we have a system of justice anymore
Lady Justice is no longer wearing a
blindfold thank you Mr Mayor God bless
you and thank you Lydia for having me on
the count today absolutely thank you
both so much for being such amazing
Patriots for this country and thank you
all so much for tuning in to the counts
on Lydia Serana and despite the chaos
going on in the world today remember
what a show all right so that's on
Newsmax here's NBC uh okay I don't know
what they're running here's ABC
looks like some kind of crime thing we
lost the CNN feed somehow I don't even
really know how
they're in a commercial break okay we'll
have the CNN feedback and then Fox is
running out I am curious what CNN is
doing at this point all right very good
let's continue over here I do want to
say thank you to Terry schweren who just
gifted a subscription should we open
phone lines a little bit guys is that
should we just and hear what's on
people's mind and then that way all of
these Republicans who are in the chat
who say you want to debate me you can
call in like right now if you actually
want to talk to me about something
should we do it all right let's do it
um let me get all all set up here
um
David you're not willing to debate me
first of all who why do I need to debate
you who who are you uh but let's hear
from some people okay uh you go to
davidpackman.com Discord we do these
things via Discord join the waiting
Lobby
um I will just start one right now we
will call it uh Trump indictment
calls and start
there we go
um and let's let's hear from some people
you know I mean if the Republicans they
need to talk to me about what's going on
okay well let's let's talk
um how about let's go to Walter from uh
oh wait you know what here's Bobby po
here's the guy Bobby debate me sir go
what do you want to debate about
hello how are you I'm doing well
glad to hear
um I honestly didn't expect this I kind
of just hopped off and came back and I
saw this like whoa because you're the
one who said like I wouldn't debate
anyone and I wouldn't debate you and all
this stuff wouldn't you know strong word
it was a short statement but I do
appreciate you for taking me on Pleasure
um I'm not sure the spill over which
direction this will go so I'll just
start with like a blanket statement I
guess and I'll just get your opinion on
that okay sorry okay
so my question
so so and just for context you're a big
Trump supporter you said right
um
I mean in the grand scheme of things in
the moment with you know the way things
are going I would say
Trump is probably a better decision than
most people okay but you in the Super
Chat you said you're a hardcore trumpy
right that's what those were yours I did
quotes because you know most people I
feel like just kind of
do a character battle and kind of just
demean the person instead of just kind
of attack the points I make so I was
just kind of just oh boy you know cool
yeah all right you use quotes fine all
right so let's let's hear it we're
debating now let's do it let's debate so
my question is so first off have you
ever seen the Doomsday Clock of the
scientific Doomsday Clock on where they
believe Society like how close
I have seen it it's not interesting to
me and I that's not interested I've
never looked at it in detail but I know
that we're all we're perpetually between
one and Five Minutes to Midnight or
something like that okay yeah so
obviously you would you would believe a
scientist's opinion on that that's
obviously going to hold some weight I
don't know so do would I believe a
scientist's opinion I tend to believe
the consensus of experts in the field in
which they are experts I don't know
enough about the Doomsday Clock to know
what scientists in What fields say what
about it you know okay well yeah I think
it's basically a metaphor I don't know
that that Doomsday Clock issue Origins
originally it was actually created by
Einstein who obviously was part of
creating nukes and he obviously foresaw
the the future right that damn nukes are
around and this could take out all
society and he was the one who created
this okay so in foresight he created
this committee that groups basically all
the top experts in the world that get
together but this is your big debate as
a trump guy you want to talk about the
Doomsday Clock
um I mean you know in the moment I'm not
going to say I'm like totally prepared
because like you're everyone was making
it seem like I couldn't even talk to you
until Wednesday so I just hopped on
right now listen let me see if I can
talk you through some stuff hold on hold
on hold on please because I I I was like
because this is very important I feel
like because obviously yes I would like
to talk to Doomsday Clock is think about
if a nuke dropped on us right now
everything you're talking about is
completely absolutely
meaningless right what is this if
everybody I don't know that much about
the Doomsday club and I just don't know
why it matters I just don't get why you
keep talking over me I can't even finish
a statement you're losing the audience
with this topic Bobby who cares I'm
trying to have an articulate argument
it's like we can't even talk because you
keep just talking over me you care about
your audience or do you actually compare
it do you care about society and making
a meaningful change that just seems like
maybe just care to Pander to your
leftist audience instead of actually
talking about things that matter because
what I'm trying to do it
I didn't ask a question I'm still going
you just I'm trying to care about mine
so do I care about Society yeah because
I'm trying to get to the point though
because it seems like you're just trying
to Pander to whatever people want to
hear but you're not actually trying to
get to the root cause because yes I may
be more on the right but I'm actually an
extremely moderate person and logical
and can come to a compromise and that's
the thing most people are missing and
already can see that's not what you're
going to try to do here but I would hope
we could come to a compromise but yes I
will now give you the floor I appreciate
you for letting me finish
um okay no so you had asked the question
do I care more about my audience or
society and I care about both and I
don't see either as being properly
served by you and I talking about the
Doomsday Clock that's all I was going to
say but I'll turn it back to you so you
can make your point or raise your
question remember you were eager to
debate me so we're I'm ready
so here's here's the point I'm trying to
make right so you right when so Trump
was running for president in 2016-2017
you as with your platform you were
making and I would say most media 99 of
the left your impression was that if
Trump became president the world would
end the United States would collapse
essentially right the worst case
scenario if Trump became president right
I never said that so I okay
one request Bobby if you want to debate
me debate me about things I've said or
that I believe rather than things some
leftists somewhere said because that I
that's not a good that's not a good
thing you know that's fair can you
please then so just so I'm aware of with
context can you then tell me your
opinion on that matter just for you just
a brief summary my concern was that
Trump would debase and embarrass the
United States through his cartoonish
nature I believe that I was Vindicated
on that in that Global opinion of the
United States and of the American
presidency was in the toilet while Trump
was President I also believe that Trump
would fail to accomplish close to all of
the things he claimed he would
accomplish and that's also true and I
believe that the things Trump would do
would mostly not be good for the country
and I believe I was Vindicated there as
well and we can look at whether it's
usmca or the Chinese tariffs or how he
handled covet so those were the three
things I believed ahead of time and I
would I would argue I was Vindicated on
all ahead of time oh well hold on right
because we're talking about I asked for
like the 2016-27 election the original
2017 election the election was November
16. okay right I'm just talking
estimates the first time Trump was
President right your opinion was was it
oh my God this guy let don't do not
allow him by the any nuclear device yes
or no I I don't remember ever saying
first of all I the word
but it will allow him near a nuclear
device I don't remember saying that no I
mean certainly Bobby hold on a second
please you're asking me questions yeah
it was a yes or no you know
I never said don't allow this guy near
any nuclear device I never said that you
believe that yes or no I was concerned
about Trump's lack of understanding of
the power of nuclear weapons okay as
demons Bobby please let me you're asking
questions and not letting me answer all
right I'm sorry I was concerned about
Trump having the type of access to nukes
that presidents have
because he demonstrated a lack of
understanding of the seriousness of
nuclear weapons
for example when he seemed not to
understand how crazy it would be to Nuke
Europe and when he asked about nuking
hurricane so for those reasons I was
concerned about Trump having access to
the Arsenal yes okay so just so I can
dumb it down for stupid people like me
you're just trying to say yes you were
trying to Advocate on your platform that
if Donald Trump got near these nuclear
devices the likelihood of the world
ending was significantly higher just due
to the fact of him being in that
position not even remotely what I'm
saying no Bobby you are I don't know and
I don't know if you're deliberately
misstating the things I'm saying
understanding them it feels like you're
filibustering because I must just not be
understanding then so can you just
explain it in a less filibustering way
and just in a more of a summary because
it didn't make sense then because I
don't I want to be polite here I I just
don't know if we're going to be able to
establish a mutual understanding of
you're not trying to you're trying to
kick me off and you're literally just
filibustering Bobby I've given you more
time than I ever give anyone that's
ridiculous you haven't given me enough
time we should have like an hour we
haven't gotten anywhere I mean you're
filibustering purposely and if your
whole audience should easily see that I
mean you're literally filibustering and
we're not getting anywhere
I'm Gonna Let You Go okay it's wondering
what filibustering is you won the debate
okay you won the debate everywhere this
is why I don't debate Trump numbers
because you won you won buddy okay
you won you won Bobby one okay Bobby's
gone
folks we can't do it right I mean it's
just like I don't think he could
understand
I know you Bobby won okay everybody
Bobby won wow people seem to have liked
that PC I just looked PC hippie Hendrix
I I am shocked that that drivel got
people to sign up uh Steve Ellis welcome
new member Lynn mazeka as well as James
Hoover and Jacob Angus you know it's
like I'm willing to entertain that stuff
every time but we go 20 minutes and he
he doesn't understand a single thing
that I'm saying
uh it's like how long do I have to do
that
how long do I have to do that before we
say I tried guys I tried
all right let's go to Walter from
Colorado and for all trumpists are
welcome here okay geez Walter welcome
what's going on
hey thanks for taking my call David
pleasure are you on a Bluetooth or
speaker right now uh I am on a speaker
okay I figured go ahead
um yeah so uh I am uh currently a law
student
um so I'm just seeing everything that's
going on with Trump from kind of baby
lawyer perspective and um it's it's
interesting I think something that
people aren't really taking into
consideration is how long this process
is gonna take
[Applause]
I mean
um you know just the whole the whole
criminal law process is is gonna take a
while especially with
um with somebody in in Trump's position
yes I think you're right it's going to
take a while
um and you know I I am uh I'm also just
kind of worried about just the Public's
reaction
um obviously mostly on the right a
little bit on the left as well because I
think that people on the left a lot of
times you know we get really excited
about oh you know this is what's going
to bring Trump down but
there's been so many so many things oh
totally Walter listen the report is that
Trump expects to be arrested I Trump's
not doing a day in prison I maintain
that I I you know it's uh I think we
should have we should be managing
expectations reasonably here I 100 agree
with you
um I I I think if anything you know
maybe some kind of a plea deals is is
gonna happen
um but it's going to be a very long
process yeah this isn't going to trial I
think that's pretty safe to say
yeah yeah
um all right very good Walter from
Colorado I'm gonna let you go because I
have a lot of people here standing by
and people eager to get on let's go next
to Jeremy from Oregon we are taking
calls Donald Trump expects to be
arrested on Tuesday Jeremy welcome
what's on your mind today
I'm waiting patiently David
um I don't really have a question just
wanted to call and say hi the first guy
that was a clown
um how badly did he crush me in that
debate Jeremy oh my god dude it was like
uh he was they built like the worst like
worst case scenario from the beginning
and it was
I don't know but yeah man a long time
listener first time caller uh yeah uh
have a good one all right Jeremy from
Oregon great to hear from you and uh the
phone glitching out at just the perfect
time let's go to Daniel from Nevada
Daniel welcome to the program
um we are potentially only 72 hours from
the arrest of Donald Trump Daniel from
Nevada you have to accept my invitation
welcome
Daniel
can you hear me now yeah what kind of a
device are you on
uh I am
awesome oh God Daniel all right what's
going on
um so we're on the preface we're on the
precipice uh indicting Trump yes and I'm
hoping that we can have them out of here
eventually but
the kind of pessimistic side of me is
like it's going like
what are the chances that Teflon Don
just escapes to Russia you know I think
it is extremely unlikely that Donald
Trump escapes to Russia I would bet
against that if it were me
okay yeah it's just that kind of
pessimistic side that's that's seen all
the times he's escaped Justice before
and it's like
is is failure gonna be snatched from the
jaws of Victory you know it's a deep
philosophical question and one I think
we have to wait to answer
okay
well thank you so much all right Daniel
great to hear from you let's do a few
super chats memberships are dumping in
after that Bobby call people loving it
Cheryl Shirley as well as Tyler O'Neill
and Jack Goodall have signed up at
joinpakman.com using the code indite I
also want to say thank you to uh oh no
no one else okay let's do a couple other
super chats brand of ham says filibuster
yeah right he just wants to hijack your
stream
um Nicholas says I have to pretend to be
dumb 75 of my work day to avoid Bobby's
thank you for making this a safe space
to be the smartest person in the room
once in a while uh my pleasure Nick
um you gave a logical answer with your
reasoning behind the answers and Bobby
just can't grasp that rationality he
just wanted simple yes or no
disappointing approach from Bobby
Gustavo says that interaction with the
trumpist was hurtful although I can't
stop laughing it was really hard to
watch I know I apologize
Bobby would make Sam Cedar quake in his
boots for real what was the point did
the Doomsday Clock get 20 minutes closer
with his Trump arrest yeah I don't know
I don't know where we were going we
might have gotten to where we were going
by tomorrow Jeff Oriel just signed up on
my website joinpakman.com let's hear
from a few other people any other
trumpists if you're waiting please uh
let's see here why don't we go to Josh
from Michigan
Michigan was a state where in 2020 there
were massive dumps of ballots we learned
Josh you know that
yeah it's going to be wild Biden in
2024. I'm sorry to be a bummer well
welcome
I just wondering if Trump drops the soap
in the shower in jail should he be
afraid or not okay so listen I know
you're being funny but here's the thing
for me the prison rape thing I don't
joke about prison rape for this reason
Josh and I know you're B I know you're
just being funny I know you're just
being funny no I know I know but here's
the thing
sometimes you hear this thing oh uh
child predator is going to prison sure
he got 10 years but he's gonna get more
than just the 10 years right
here's the thing about it the fact that
our prisons are such a disaster that we
can't even keep inmates safe to me is
really a failing not like you're gonna
get a bonus punishment you know what I'm
saying Josh right yeah the punitive
damage is awful in this country right
now yes uh right exactly yeah
but anyway I don't think Trump's going
to do a day of prison anyway so it's all
sort of just you know hypothetical
yeah my joke just I hope he does and uh
it was great to touch base with you here
David all right Josh from Michigan
dumping in with some commentary right
away thanks to Spence for signing up
with twitch prime your member uh 129
today Donald Trump expects to be
arrested on Tuesday and we are taking
calls from the great people in the
audience and I am learning from you
let's go to I hope I'm pronouncing this
correctly is it darcele in Texas is that
the right pronunciation
yeah uh that's correct hold on one sec
I'm trying to get this on speaker real
quick no no don't use speaker speaker is
bad you sound good now don't don't don't
do speaker
okay so can you hear me yes I got
okay
um first off I want to at least say I do
have um autism and ADHD so it can give
me a little bit of miscommunication
issues so well you're doing great so far
my friend
thank you so much
um so first of all if I want to at least
say sorry you have to deal with that
Trump supporter earlier I mean he was
really cringing me out and stuff like
that no no listen I want to talk to
people with different views it's just
like we can't even start the
conversation you know what I'm saying
and it's like it's a very frustrating
thing
yeah I actually do have a couple of
friends like if I even try to do speak
politics with them they
um always want to hear a simple answer
and it's like I can't really give that
to them because they won't understand it
right but anyways um I wanted to at
least ask um
recently there are have been
um the truth social with Trump yep
saying he wants people to protest on on
Tuesday when he goes into court do you
think
um there will be still a lot more people
gonna participate and will the National
Guard be ready for any of that stuff or
do you think it's just like nobody's
gonna come so here's the thing I I
genuinely don't know I don't believe
that the National Guard will be pulled
in I could be wrong but NYPD is so
massive and there are so many other law
enforcement agencies with major
presences in New York City that I don't
actually think they're going to need the
National Guard that's my hope I all I
hope there's no violence whatsoever the
other aspect to this is you know if you
look at the places in the country that
have the most Trump supporters it's not
New York city so my hope darcele is that
there is no violence and anyway that the
Trump people who would be violent aren't
anywhere near New York City anyway
okay and um I also have another question
uh with this um Trump indictment do you
think uh it's going to hurt
um for the 2024 Republicans if Trump
does get indicted or will it pretty much
not be at all you know to tell you the
truth I think Trump getting arrested is
going to Galvanize his supporters and it
might even help him in the primary I I
hate that this is the situation but I
think if I'm totally honest with you
which is all I would ever be I think it
might help him
yeah I mean I guess at some point in
ways I do understand what your um uh
going with that especially with Trump
getting indicted but at least I would
think like at least a couple of
supporters who haven't fallen into
Trump's scam uh would step out of it
because
um because it uh they saw the indictment
and everything information is out there
but again most of the people who still
support Trump are uh people who just
want a yes or no uh answer and just get
yes well and listen here's the thing
at this point if you still support Trump
you're not going to abandon him because
he gets indicted right I mean because
think about who what would have to be
going on in your head for you to still
support them I don't think the
indictment will make a difference
all right then and also this is going to
be my last question and I'll end it here
um I don't know
um uh if uh you've been aware I know
this is more of Texas politics I know
you're more focused into Trump but
um
do you think
um with everything that has Ted Cruz has
done like like with the whole um him
leaving during
um the freeze which I had to deal with
that it was awful yeah um didn't have
power for two weeks oh my goodness I
didn't have power for three hours last
week and I was like what the hell am I
gonna do
yeah but um
do you actually think
um Ted Cruz has
more of a chance losing than ever
compared to
um last
um four years you mean as a senator
yes uh you know I don't know enough
about Texas politics to say for sure but
I think Ted Cruz's seat is pretty safe
yeah I mean there was that one time
where Beto was super close to Ted Cruz
and
and uh let's also not forget to like
despite
um what the prediction's been so far
um Texas has been turning into a lean
left facility now because let's hope I
still think it's an uphill battle but I
think it is moving in that direction
listen darcia you've asked three
beautiful questions I'm Gonna Let You Go
it was great hearing from you no no it's
great it's great hearing from you too
I'm glad to be on your show all right
darcille from Texas polite direct clear
folks hard to ask for a better caller
let's go oh thank you to Mark Rowe and
Teresa long who both just got
memberships on my website also
Eris
says David Kyle and crystal said earlier
today Bragg was supposed to have one
more witness next week next week for the
case and are aiming to interview on
Thursday have you came across that
report as well I have not let me
investigate
and Austin says do you think this
indictment will affect him running for
president no I think if there's a bunch
though they might thank you to Leslie
from Colorado Springs for the twitch
Prime subscription let's keep it going
let's go next to Dev from Virginia Dev
from Virginia welcome to the live stream
Donald Trump says he will be arrested on
Tuesday that is the main topic today and
it's so great to hear from so many of
you
hi David how's it going it's going well
good uh so I just want to make one quick
point about possible protests in New
York if he's indicted and why we don't
why we don't have to worry about too
many protesters it's actually pretty
simple okay um once they see the tolls
going across the bridges and tunnels
they're gonna go right back to where
they came that's actually very true now
I'm trying to remember I always forget
because some of the bridges
I I have like the you know the Easy Pass
thing some of the bridges the tolls are
they only coming into Manhattan or only
going out uh last time I remember when I
lived there was just going in so it's
not okay because it'd be funny if they
came in if it was free going in they do
their protesting then they leave and
they're in they're dinged 40 bucks on
tolls yeah yeah they've been for a rude
surprise after that would be funny no
you may you may be right but listen I
hope there's no violence that's really
the problem me too of course I just like
to make fun when I can no it makes sense
you can leave for free but you pay to go
to New York City that doesn't mean right
yeah yeah yeah exactly thanks David all
right Deb from Virginia making a
beautiful beautiful Point let's go to
Jake from California Jake from
California welcome you are on
well not yet you have to accept I guess
Jake from California please please
please hi can you hear me yes I can
okay awesome sorry about that
um I just wanted to uh you might hate me
for this but I wanted to kind of dredge
up the Norfolk Southern rail disaster
okay and you know I know that you have
engaged with some of the really bad
faith and homophobic criticism of like
people to judge regarding that but yeah
I'm just wondering have you kind of
heard
anything any of the I guess kind of like
good faith left-wing criticisms of him
regarding that yes I mean listen I'll
I'll be totally upfront with you I think
the reaction from the Biden
Administration was slower than it should
have been given what was predictably
going to be the narrative from the right
now if you come to me and you say
do Pete budege and Biden really need to
go there in order to do anything no but
it's so predictable and Trump trump
really was sort of like clever in going
there and I do think Buddha judge and
Biden they I'm not attacking how
interested they are in dealing with it
but I do think that they they miss the
the opportunity there to actually get
there and get there quickly
I was referring to more of like
you know what Pete could have done as
you know kind of the dot regarding
regulations
I'm completely willing to be told
specifically what he should have done
and when and evaluate it and be critical
I also am aware that a lot of these
trained things are dealt with at the
state level if I understand correctly
speaking to some friends who work for
for various railroads there is of course
Federal oversight on Rail and a lot of
rail crosses from one state into another
so there's a hundred percent Federal
Authority but my understanding is that
some of these things like for example in
Ohio the frequency on the track where
they install these Hot Box detectors
which it could have detected the fire
earlier apparently those are State
decisions again this is if I understand
correctly so then you could be like well
peach should have pressured the state to
put it in but the governor is a
republican so I just don't know you know
I'm glad to criticize but I want to make
sure that I'm these are accurate
criticisms there you go no worries fair
enough uh thanks for taking a call all
right Jake from California uh very uh
good good questions powerful questions I
would say thank you to Dennis Sandberg
and Maya roselip who signed up on my
website folks we are a community
supported thing the tick tocks we're
launching on Snapchat soon the Spanish
channel the podcast all this stuff it's
mostly funded by people who go to my
website and get a membership tonight
because we're awaiting the indictment of
trump the arrest of trump the coupon
code indict works and it gets you a huge
discount I also want to say thanks to
kill that Feats who just signed up via
twitch Prime
let's hear from a few more people and
there are a lot of people here a lot of
people here that are trying to get on
let's go to Alec from Rhode Island Alec
from Rhode Island welcome
Alec please accept the invitation there
you are
hey David can you hear me okay yes I can
fantastic so uh I was just hoping you
could speak a little more to why you
think Donald Trump will serve no time
behind bars I so let's work backwards
okay
yeah I think or well I guess we'll work
forwards uh in order I right now I think
the most likely scenario is that any
indictments end with a plea agreement
and the plea agreement worst case would
be home confinement and not prison like
I just think it's that simple
okay and and then just quick follow-up
with that being said if he's not to
spend any time Behind Bars what do you
think the repercussions of that like you
know regardless of any indictments if he
doesn't serve time Behind Bars what do
you think the backlash from you know
the the left is going to be towards that
what's the message we're sending to the
country if he doesn't actually serve
time Behind Bars it's going to take
years to resolve this or potentially all
of the cases and Trump will be a very
old man by the time these things are
resolved and I think it's all going to
end with a whimper
I unfortunately agree with you thank you
very much all right my pleasure there is
Alec from Rhode Island great calls today
really fantastic calls today let's go
next to Noah from California Noah from
California welcome what's on your mind
today
Noah from California please unmute
yourself
hello yes there you are oh sorry about
that I was muted you um
so I wanted to ask you about
the arrest
um I was circling around some
conservative uh
subreddits and stuff earlier and a lot
of them seem to be of the mind that Ron
DeSantis is gonna benefit greatly from
this arrest and it's gonna clear the
clear the weight of the nomination for
him I just wanted to know what you think
about that right now
I don't think that that's the case I
think Trump supporters will be very
heavily galvanized by the arrest but let
me make a caveat to that Noah I think
the scenario that does help desanctus is
if
this becomes this arrest becomes a huge
encumbrance to Trump
or if this arrest opens the floodgates
to more charges and then it becomes
impossible for Trump to even run a
campaign and it starts to be clear that
he's struggling to run the campaign
because of the legal problems I think in
that case it will help wrong to Sanctus
but I think that just this initial
arrest is likely to Galvanize Trump
supporters
okay that's interesting opinions and
predictions so I could be completely
wrong you know
yeah yeah I was just I was thinking
about it too like with the leaks from
Tucker Carl the Tucker Carlson text
leaks and the producers and all that
like the right really seems to kind of
be turning on Trump behind closed doors
yeah so yeah I'm curious to see if like
when it happens you know what way it's
gonna go I guess like you said it's all
just predictions at this point so
we will be watching it closely though
that's for damn sure very closely thank
you David all right Noah from California
great to hear from you let's go next to
Bell from Pennsylvania also a website
member at joinpakman.com Belle welcome
to the stream and thank you for
supporting on the website as well I
appreciate that
thank you David hi uh I have one simple
question please
um
what are the prices of mangoes where you
are currently so you may or may not
believe this but I just was very
recently at the Union Square Whole Foods
and some people pronounce it Manhattan
some people say Manhattan like I know
people who pronounce it almost like it's
a d but that's the topic for a different
day Bell and um they had this is
actually pretty expensive they had
organic with my Amazon discount and the
whole thing organic mango for 1.99 each
wow
not a terrible Province right
oh yeah not too bad I went to the store
today and they were actually a dollar
each so oh my gosh looking up a dollar
each that's that's a fantastic price
absolutely you probably bought a hundred
I'm guessing I only bought one actually
oh okay
well uh was that all you had today bill
that's that's all I had my girlfriend
wanted me to ask you that question okay
good and by the way for all the talking
about mango there are so many other
great fruits I don't want mango to oh
get all the the spotlight you know
absolutely peaches are better for sure
well that that I don't know about but
let's before we get into an argument I'm
Gonna Let You Go okay all right thank
you all right Belle from Pennsylvania
checking in very very strongly about
fruits and elements of fruit let's go
next to Haley from Maryland Haley
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today and thank you for your
continued support as well
hey David can you hear me yes I can
awesome so I just moved from Georgia I
don't know if you noticed my name
changed right well I was thinking
because I remember Haley from Georgia
and now you're Haley from Maryland yeah
yes I just moved uh changed my job and
everything
um so I have been thinking a lot since
moving to a bigger city I was living in
Augusta Georgia before
um about
like
the the you know the the Wright likes to
talk about uh you know the Second
Amendment rights and everything
um which you know it's in the
Constitution I totally agree with it yes
but uh what about the right to vote and
what about their right to vote for
homeless people because hold on now I
wanna Haley can I I want there's a there
was a grammatical ambiguity are you
talking about the right to vote for
candidates who are homeless or the right
for homeless people to vote in elections
they're right for homeless people to
vote in elections got it okay got it got
it got it people who are citizens of
this country yes I mean you know
thousands hundred a hundred thousand
maybe cannot vote even though they are
citizens so
um my son my eight-year-old son actually
brought this up to me when we were
voting in the election and uh in Augusta
Georgia
um wait your eight-year-old son votes
what do you mean we no he he he's the
one who brought it up to me about yeah
about how homeless people cannot vote
because they don't have an address
I understand what you're saying but that
can't possibly let's see homeless people
voting without an address that's it it's
a great question
um okay so the way to do it is voting
while homeless is challenging
registering to vote people that you can
vote but they don't know
or for a lot of folks but I probably
really want to review an address
so okay right interesting so apparently
in Most states you can put in the
address of a of a social service
provider or shelter but people have to
know that they can do that yeah
and so what I would like to do now that
I'm in a big city is to do some sort of
Outreach right and I would like to
encourage all of the listeners to do
that as well if they're able
um to make sure that we get as many
voters as possible is to you know make
sure that they're registered and make
sure that they have IDs for states that
require identification and that is
actually a fascinating thing right if if
there was a targeted effort to say hey
by the way uh you know if people are
requesting money or whatever the case
may be to bring up this issue of are you
even registered to vote I mean I think
everyone should vote for sure but that
is interesting yeah you've got the right
idea Haley I think yeah and I just you
know let's applaud my son he's the one
who who recognized this before even I
did nice job yeah congratulations to
Haley's son
uh nice to speak to you again David all
right likewise and hope the transition
to Maryland has gone well great to hear
from Haley let's go to Janice from Texas
Janice from Texas also a website member
thank you for supporting at
joinpakman.com oh no Denise right is
this Janiece you got it okay I I
realized what I was doing is it Janiece
welcome
good memory how are you I'm doing well
awesome
um so I was going to ask how you feel
about well I'm kind of steering off the
topic by the way I loved what Haley was
saying about the homelessness issue I
had a passion about that here in Austin
Texas but anyways I digress my question
is relating to the abortion topic now
that we're in Texas it's pretty intense
over here obviously
um and so whenever I'm talking to people
who are on the opposite side of the
opinion as I am I just like to bring up
that you know men haven't been
restricted in any ways so you know I
told them all Texas continues to go down
this route I'm just going to get really
intense and start saying we need to
criminalize every male that impregnates
a woman and start turning that
prosecution around I mean let's just say
that
nothing's going to change this is how it
is women are screwed so let's turn the
conversation around and you know
criminalize the men what do you think
well uh Janiece I I totally understand
the concept of what you're saying it
seems like a legal impossibility
basically
um you're saying if a man impregnates a
woman the man has committed a crime
uh not necessarily he's created a like
created a crime or but he's a part of it
like if a woman can be jailed or
sentenced to death for having an
abortion there is another person
involved with it so you're saying
right if a woman is charged for having
obtained an abortion
the man who impregnated her could also
be charged you're saying it is 50 50. it
takes imagine to get a woman pregnant a
woman this is a lot less crazy than I
thought at first yeah no it makes total
sense a woman if she if a woman has a
new partner every single day she can
still technically only conceive one
child a year unless there's some you
know scientific stuff whatever but a man
could have a new partner every single
day and impregnate 365 women with that
leap year you know 366. so we're really
we've been regulating the wrong sex
that's February 29th baby is really a
special one no what you're saying is
it's a very interesting concept I have
to say I mean of course we're speaking
completely hypothetically it'll never
happen
the man is an accessory to the crime 100
well he is he's the culprit it's him no
woman has an orgasm and has a baby it is
a male orgasm that creates a child so
we're looking at the inability I mean we
can go forever and ever but we're
looking at a man's inability to withhold
right and it's them it's always them and
they're the ones pushing the laws on us
they're the ones that can't control it
it's just a huge problem so we need to
talk about
sex you know it's the thing that they
don't want to talk about they don't want
to talk to talk about it but it is
natural we do it and it's time to start
you know really talking about
the body in a you know of
a scientific physiological way I'm a
massage therapist you know there's bones
there's muscles there's tendons let's
talk about it as science but you know
they don't like science Janiece you're
not the massage therapist who emailed me
after my rant about the toxins right
that was something no no I didn't but I
loved your topic on that actually
because I used to be a yoga instructor
full time and after the pandemic I
noticed how a lot of my community kind
of went you know a different route so
yeah massage therapy is tangible I love
what I do but I'm also getting my degree
in uh computer science because that's
you know another realm of income but
yeah my brain my brain's doing a lot but
yeah the yoga community did a little
thing uh and I don't know if they're
coming back some of them are yeah we did
an interview about that I don't know if
you saw it yeah I did it was great all
right Janiece from Texas are you going
to Joe Rogan's new anti-cancel culture
uh comedy club in Austin
I didn't know about it yeah you I guess
like you can't get canceled at this club
and there's also no heckling allowed
oh I'm interested to see how that turns
out yep all right all right great to
hear from you again I appreciate it
later all right there it goes Janice
from Texas with a number of powerful
declarations I do have to say let's go
to Doug from I hope I'm pronouncing this
correctly is it Sioux Falls South Dakota
is that the correct pronunciation
oh Doug you got to help me out by
unmuting yourself for the love of God
Doug
sorry about that there you are is it is
it Sioux Falls or Sioux Falls
no that corrects at Sioux Falls Sioux
Falls beautiful
um I had a couple of questions
um the Second Amendment uh piece uh
for a well-regulated militia how can you
be well regulated if your militia is
potentially sick which
the reason I don't delve into the
well-regulated element is
I see a lot of disagreement when you and
I here regulated we think of Regulation
like the way the government you know
like OSHA regulates workplaces we think
of that but there are Divergent opinions
about whether regulation meant something
different in that context and I just am
not a legal scholar myself so I've
avoided delving into that
yeah okay yeah
fair enough and then
um the abortion topic
um
why isn't miscarriage brought up more uh
it's an abortion I think it is I mean I
think it's it's I see it brought up all
the time in the context of some of these
anti-abortion laws could actually
criminalize miscarriage as well
depending on the the most common cases
if the miscarriage is from quote
negligence it could be criminalized and
then negligence is very much you know
does negligence mean you didn't take a
prenatal vitamin you know there's the
negligence is very very squishy and so I
do think that the the miscarriage issue
is talked about
fair enough yeah well thank you David
all right Doug from Sioux Falls South
Dakota big thank you to Simon Bennett
and James grimplin who both just signed
up on my website new members 136 and 137
also a big thank you to if it fits as
well as gunken who uh signed up via
twitch Prime twitch and related twitch
products folks that is it for today
72 hours from now Trump may be indicted
if it happens we will be live live live
live and it's been so great to see
everybody here remember it's free to
subscribe on YouTube and it's free to
follow on Twitch please do it and you'll
be notified about future streams that I
do which is a delightful thing all right
we'll see everybody very soon
foreign